um wait so the one thing you said in the
tick tock that went viral you said that
you should not stay at a job for more
than two years
and when i heard this i thought it was
shocking because i've always been told
you have to show people that you're
loyal to a company
yeah i think that's an outdated old
school method
and all of the data will support me on
that statement no longer really does
anyone our age is anyone even close to
our generation graduate work at one
company for 20 years 40 years that's
gone you're not getting a gold watch at
your 50th like at your retirement
that's not how it works because the data
shows that if you stay at a job every
year you're probably getting
a three to five percent raise and that's
only to combat inflation maybe every two
to three years you get a 10 raise which
is like industry standard for within an
organization to the next level
however if you leave your company
and go in a lateral position
realistically it raises somewhere
between 20 and 25 percent
um there's a lot of reasons obviously
for that and the reason that i
personally said to do it after like 18
months to 24 months is because at that
point you have a good understanding of
what your current role is you probably
already have a good amount of
achievements in there realistically you
probably stopped learning anything new
or like what i would always run into at
yelp at google and even now at walmart
is like you run out of almost like
things in your scope in your area that
you have ownership of and maybe maybe
this is just true with bigger companies
startups obviously everything you're
wearing a lot of hats you're running
around but i think there's pros and cons
to obviously both sides of this
yeah like she's saying down there like
prove yourself through grunt work right
that's why i worked at yelp for close to
two years i mean that's a miserable
sales job but a lot of people start out
their careers there
because it shows that you have
some form of like ability to learn and
get
[Music]
experience so tell me
how did you get a job at google
that's like the um
like nobody gets a job at google
yeah you got a job at google and then
you left like that's
crazy nice
yeah um so i would say like my getting
into google was unique because they
approached me or i got i got reached out
to on linkedin i think that was a
combination of like i had like i keep my
linkedin very updated i keep that very
up to date i use all the correct like
buzzwords business words if you anyone
watching this needs help with that um go
check out one sultan
he's a good friend of mine you work
the linkedin is to stand out but i got
approached by some headhunter recruiter
who was hiring for a new ad product that
google was launching in the home service
space and so working at yelp
i was very familiar with that space uh
that was like our best sellers basically
and so i i took the call from this guy
and then quickly realized that the
product that they were building out was
gonna put yelp out of business it was
gonna put home advisor and angie's list
out of business
and so when i realized i even had like a
small foot in the door to google just
through this like even as a phone call i
just decided i was not gonna let
anything
stop me from getting as far down the
track with them as possible so that went
all the way to them being like oh you're
not in the bay area
we can't hire you because this is still
like a stealth mode startup level org
and we're only hired from the bay
because we don't have a relocation
budget and i was like well what if i pay
for my own flight out there for my
interview and my own housing in my own
relocation like you guys don't have to
do that and i just fought down like
every objection they could possibly
handle that right everything that
possibly throw at me
uh it worked really well for me because
initially i was approached for a sales
job
and through my interview process
i showed up to the interview my
in-person interview that i paid for my
own plan to get out to paid for my own
airbnb all that stuff i showed it for
the interview and i felt something was
weird
so i went through the interview the
interview was fine but i could tell
something was off and i didn't so two
weeks after which as long as i had heard
not heard from them i got to call that
the position i had interviewed for phil
um and i was like you know that's a
bummer that's a huge bummer but hey i
did everything i could and that's like i
just i just don't want to live with
regrets on it but i google called me and
showed some interest i couldn't just let
that go and be like oh you know five
years from now what if i had done that i
would i wouldn't just like
i can't live like that um
so they were like so we filled that
position however the team really likes
you and they are opening another
position on the operation side
if you have any experience with sql and
with like database stuff and i told them
very honestly i don't i was just like
have some data i have some data
experience um because i'm salesforce
certified through
like our leadership development program
but i'm like if you want sql i'll learn
i'll learn before i get there
and i guess that was good enough for
them uh so they took me for that
position and i showed up
a week and a half later
uh to google with a
book called how google works in two sql
certifications